hi I'm Monica the beauty expert I am
Ashley the coordination maven and today
we're going to help one woman avoid a
corner like Christmas I just moved in
with my boyfriend and I totally took
over his space
so I've been having some problems sure
what I'm looking for is some ways of
like getting organized or learning how
to share the space to prevent a future
fight so I actually want to surprise him
with this a surprise he's going away so
I want to surprise him and be like look
at our shirt yeah you fell over next
steps is we're gonna get into your place
figure out how we can like organize the
closet and bathroom I have gotten a
little messy my step currently is just
sort of like in a little corner and
yours is sort of like everywhere else
maybe a little bit more organization
wouldn't hurt is there any like
particularly reason you're asking it's
making me hold this camera we gotta
investigate your bathroom situation as
you can see everything is just
everywhere what do you feel when you see
all this stuff out does it bother you at
all or do you just put up with that no
it really bothers me what I want you to
try to do is to streamline your whole
routine I see you have a lot of skincare
stuff you can consolidate all that into
one product that I'm gonna give you it's
the yeah it's the Olay pro-x I mean one
so you don't have to worry about you
know like moisturizer SPF all that stuff
it's all one bottle great organizing tip
is sorting like with like purging what
no longer serves and then having a home
for everything focus on your stuff for
now and then if you come across Jacob
stuff go ahead and move it to the
side and we want to make sure he has his
section and you have yours yeah so I
started my makeup and I scourge the
obvious things and now I'm supposed to
search like the not-so of these things
but I think is this gonna okay so I'm
about to try the product it's supposed
to moisturize and firm and brighten
I wouldn't has SPF which is really
important because my lane it's very
sunny ever since I moved from New York
my skin has gone crazy and my skin
products like aren't working anymore
look really soft this is my stuff that
was on the floor this is all of his
clothes are on the floor I've done
enough for today so we watched your
vlogs and you've done so much yeah you
can saleh dated your skincare I haven't
seen you work in that closet and getting
rid of some of those clothes yeah but I
feel like my clothes in my closet aren't
representing like who I was in New York
organizing that and getting rid of
things means I'm closing the door on
that part of my life and now I'll just
be like Who I am in LA and I like don't
know what that means yeah it makes it so
official right it makes ya real you're
actually claiming this right and that
can be a little scary but we got you you
got yourself yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm so tired I put it off long enough
it's time to accept the reality that I
live in a sunny place and that these
jackets just gotta go jacket number one
I feel like I could wear it with pants
or a dress it's giant and it's hot I
know in my brain that I read this a ton
I know that as a person like this jacket
is more like true to me so I feel like I
actually really do you know who I am
like here in LA and what I want so it
feels good and I feel like confident
okay how do you think Olivia did with
all this it's not easy but I bet you
that she's really pushed herself okay I
think I think it's time to decide dive
in and watch you see what's cooking
[Applause]
surprise you're nervous I'm a little
nervous to expect whoa oh my God look at
that really so nice here's half of her
stuff is gone
she really perched a jacket half of it
is your clothes and half of its mine
clothes and then these are your clothes
organized some - later - heaviest layer
thank you this is so much oh he's so
pressed
[Music]
glowing yeah gotta see more oh yeah my
stuff's in the baskets your basket yeah
this basket remember always gang your
brothers
yeah yeah I just have one bottle of
monitor nearness me an organ I'm Monica
thank you very much yeah looking really
tired miss Jim you did all of this was :
yeah you're so cool yeah she really did
a good job
[Music]